tout de noir vêtu typé ville voici le
hic gotham dernier né de look cycle y
signe l'entrée de la marque nivernaise
dans la gamme des vélos électriques
urbains un modèle haut de gamme à près
de 4500 euros le coût d'un cadre carbone
pour tenter de se démarquer de la
concurrence
pourquoi du carbone parce que csa fait
un cadre beaucoup plus léger la majorité
des vélos en aluminium électrique pèse
autour des 23 24 kg et là on est sur un
vélo qui pèse que 16 kg c'était vraiment
bien de pouvoir proposer un modèle
urbain
comme ceci sachant qu'on est quand même
spécialiste du vélo depuis à peu près 35
ans c'est vrai que jusqu'à maintenant
c'était pas forcément attardé sur ce
segment là car le positionnement de look
depuis son arrivée dans le monde du vélo
dans les années 1980 reste la
performance vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
l'entraînement l'équipe de france monte
sur le t20 son nouvel allié dans sa
quête d'or olympique à tokyo une machine
nouvelle génération pour viser le plus
haut niveau
nous en tant que sprinteur on est très
avantagés grâce à sauver il est beaucoup
plus
il est beaucoup plus léger aussi faut
pas oublier que c'est un sport qu'on
mettrait et que chaque millième compte
ça m'est déjà arrivé de perdre pour un
millième donc c'est vrai que c'est
important d'avoir des outils très
performants
la différence on la sent tout de suite
pour ça que comptait ce côté là on sera
libéré une loi traite dans notre tête
pour pouvoir tout donner tout simplement
sur un vélo une part de bourgogne qui
brillera au japon trois ans et demi de
développement dans les ateliers de
nevers pour créer ce poste de carbone le
savoir-faire deux donc c'est de pouvoir
réaliser des cadres en carbone très
performant ce cadre que vous voyez là
est composé de quatre cent soixante
pièces carbone et la fourche 75 carbone
jouer avec les limites les matières pour
atteindre un cadre d'environ 1 kg 5
une performance n'est de 35 ans
d'expérience et d'une attention portée à
chaque vélo chaque morceau et découpés à
la main suite à un travail d'orientation
ou dans ce cas là de tout simplement de
déroulage puisque ce tissu là est déjà
très s'est orientée 35 heures de travail
manuel de roulage ne des coûts vraiment
toutes les étapes et ensuite on a encore
15 heures de finition là encore du très
haut de gamme
comptez au moins 10000 euros par vélo
tout équipé le prix d'un savoir faire
français
avec 130 salariés sur le site de nevers
face à la concurrence asiatique
nous avons décidé dé garder
une partie de notre production notamment
les très haut de gamme et pour la
performance en france et ça nous donne
la confidentialité dans le développement
où certains flexibilité pour pouvoir
répondre aux exigences des athlètes dans
la manière la plus précise et rapide
avec 45 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel la société reste une
référence
son produit phare mes pédales le modèle
automatique a été inventé par look
aujourd'hui la marque propose aussi une
gamme de pédales plate le marché du vélo
évolué ce n'est plus uniquement
performance le coc vie de la montre est
également le vélo est un outil
locomotion de plus en plus plébiscités
on a un rayonnement qui est vraiment à
l'international
aujourd'hui on est distribué dans 75
pays dans le monde
on doit être capable de proposer des
produits pour tous les utilisateurs look
cycle compte bien garder sa position en
s'appuyant sur l'innovation vers le vélo
électrique ou le vtt notamment tout en
visant la performance sur la route et la
piste
à commencer par les prochains jeux de
tokyo